and if you work really hard you're
really diligent person make sure that
you do some play to balance your life
out I'm 60 years old and I've everybody
who works for me is younger than me and
they'll tell you I'll work you up under
the table need motivation what's your
top ten with believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and join today's lessons from a man who
went from dropping out of university so
he could become a preacher to having to
take a job at a carbide Factory just so
he could survive the founding a Potter's
House church and becoming a best-selling
author of multiple books
he's TD jakes and here's my take on his
top ten roses success vol 3 also if you
want to know what Bishop Jake's and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below to be anxious is
to have anxiety about something that
hasn't even happened yet that's why I
can't deal with people who cannot pick
up the pace
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be fruitful a very first command God
says to Adam is to be fruitful you can
only be fruitful if you are seed full
okay so we're talking about the
difference between fruit and seed
identifying your seed is what causes you
to be fruitful the first revelation of
seed should happen in your family you
should have parents who are looking at
their kids looking for seeds I'm gonna
give you my grandbaby story you asked
for it you're gonna get it you just so
we're in my church and it's dark and my
grandbabies in there and a bunch of
friends in there we're taking pictures
and I can't find the light and I do you
know the lights are complicated back to
you figure out how to turn out with
stuff on it and so we're trying to get
some pictures and so my grandbaby ran
and she says wait a minute Paul I'm
gonna get a flashlight she went up under
the Pew where we have hidden flashlights
snatched down a flashlight and brought
it over and said I'll take the picture
and so I said to her I said baby don't
you want to be Kensie don't you want to
be in the picture she said no I don't
want to be in the picture I want to hold
the light
that's the seed right there that's the
seat right there so we came back to the
house and I was getting ready to take a
picture and I'm trying to keep up with
you Millennials you know it's so hard
and I'm trying to take a selfie and I
was trying I got a timer you know we're
using backup nickel
if you follow me all this to rebel you
know this is true and so I couldn't get
my phone to sit up and she wouldn't got
some books and pumped it up and I said I
told my daughter I said put her in
leadership classes put her in management
classes she's a problem solver that
starts early early early her instinct in
a situation is to solve the problem she
says I don't want to be in the picture I
want to hold the light those are seeds
okay
directing that channel toward an area
where you can cultivate what God has
planted down inside of them is important
it's very very important there are
people in this room that have dormant
seeds laying inside of them that if they
get in the right atmosphere they're
gonna turn into things you have never
seen before they didn't always have the
benefit of parents who couldn't see it
or had time to see it or know how to see
it but even as adults there are still
seeds down and you that have not been
touched yet that's what happened to
Elijah he was fulfilling his parents
vision plowing in the field every boy
was no farmer
just because you can run a plow that
mean you're a farmer but sometimes we
get stuck in what people expect right
and we've never found out who we are
because we're living somebody else's
dream and so there he is plowing in the
field doing what his daddy want him
going around and said I guess this is
all life has for me and he's going
around and around a circle like many
people are listening at me right now you
go to work go to church go home go to
work go to church go home go to work go
to church go home you're flying around
around in circles until Elijah passed by
him and then he was exposed to something
the moment he was exposed to something
greater he dropped something lesser rule
number two pushed through person fix
this book up what are you warning them
to get from this I want them to
understand that you are the architect of
tomorrow I based it on the Wright
brothers who had the audacity to believe
that they could build something that
would take them from the ground to the
air and so they built this and without a
degree without having financed Sears oh
you don't need an education to make it
all
they didn't let they didn't let any of
the things that normally stop us I don't
have the money I don't have the capital
I don't have the manufactory in fact
they built the first plane in a bicycle
shop the other thing that I think is
important to mention the gravitational
pull that the Wright brothers had to
break through is a law that whatever
goes up must come down Isaac Newton was
absolutely right but they found a higher
law by pushing the limits on the lower
law they found the law of aerodynamics
most entrepreneurs when you start
building something were you trying to
build a marriage if you're trying to
build a child there is a gravitational
pull that says you don't belong up here
come down to where you belong
Wow but if you keep pushing the gifts
what's pulling you back you'll break
into another law yeah
rule number three persevere God wants
you to be excited about your destiny so
that you can endure the process that
brings you into promise because there is
a process before promise and if you
don't have at least a vision of the
promise the process will discourage you
but every time discouragement is trying
to get you to give up the process
remember the reason you have of the
promise and keep on walking around the
wall keep on walking I'm tired
around this wall I'm frustrated when I
walk around this wall walk around this
wall ministry's not warm but on
this war thought I'd be married by now
but how to walk around this wall lost
the first house the plan for the second
I walk around this wall credits on Zack
Lord but I will walk around this wall
and trusted you when I can't trace you
I'm gonna walk around this wall and lord
I am crazy enough to stand in front of a
solid wall and shout as if it had
already
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rule number four be authentic to your
core I never knew that the way people
described you would become a prison
until they did it when when I met me I
was not a preacher so I didn't know that
they would incarcerate me with the title
you are at your best when you are
authentic to your core and you have to
be what you are not what they call you
but sometimes see you appear to say what
I'm saying sometimes people will call
you a name and you start living up to
the name and it limits you from what
else God wants to do is your life rule
number five balance work with playing
the fifth thing that I really escaped to
is balance work with play you can't do
all of either one and be successful and
to those whom much is given much is
required and if you work really hard
you're really diligent person make sure
that you do some play to balance your
life out if you play real hard but you
don't work very much it'll be fun but
you're gonna be hungry you gotta balance
work with play you have to balance it
with your children if you're always too
disciplinarian your daddy gonna get you
when you get home I don't want to always
be the police in the house yeah I want
to be the fun guys sometime balancing
work with play call this not only for
you to be holistic but for people to get
a better perspective of who you are I
get on my Instagram and I put crazy
stuff my kids die
I just yesterday I put me sweating in
the gym saying they said it's gonna be
fun but it hadn't gotten fun yet you
know yeah you know to let people know
that everything is not serious every day
that's too much pressure we've gotten
way too much pressure on us to be the
people we were created to be rule number
six fight listen listen clearly
I want to pronounce a benediction
on every grieving weeping depressed
lonely frustrated tired spirit your
period of mourning is over
touch so close friend your sister girl
your cousin on me mall until I cried my
last year yesterday yesterday I cried my
last tear yesterday
- yesterday
yesterday last year
yesterday you send them flowers back you
give a sympathy card back you can stop
looking at me all pitiful
you can stop seeing me as surety
[Applause]
more than a god
[Applause]
[Music]
some quest in me
[Applause]
rule number seven have a great work
ethic I've seen people who were
underground I've seen Steve Harvey's on
this ground I've seen people on the
ground what on the ground really is is a
work ethic that would blow your mind it
would blow your mind I'm 60 years old
and I'm everybody who works for me is
younger than me and they'll tell you I
worked you up under the table I'll work
you up under the table
where does that come from my father my
father absolutely my father is Rick my
Vijay this chair is about to break my
father sitting here and my mother is
sitting here and they're fighting for
the mic from moment to moment my
grandmother talks to you every night me
and all of my ancestors are sitting on
this table all the way back to Nigeria
my ancestors were Evo's from Nigeria and
Evo's are called black Jews that they're
industrious that they go after things
that they're hardworking people so all
the way back in my DNA
we were chefs efficient and all of them
are sitting here folks whose name I
can't even call so what we're talking
about is culture okay and now not racial
culture family culture where we're the
demonstration of what my father decided
what Grandin was you were grinded your
daddy said you were grandpa not you take
your hands out your pocket more like you
got a million dollars easy [ __ ] they
trained us not to be lazy they talked
about lazy like it was a disease rule
number eight make relationships count
another point is making relationships
count making your relationships count
because everything is about
relationships you're first of all your
relationship with God your that's a very
important thing to have because as long
as you know that there's somebody in
charge you don't have to bear the brunt
of the responsibility and the weight of
what's going on in your life here you
can talk to the boss yeah number two
enjoy your relationship with yourself if
you don't like you it makes it hard for
me to like you know because people when
you walk into their atmosphere they draw
you into the cosmos of their own drama
and if they're full of drama without you
when you come in you become a nought up
in the cyclone of their drama
enjoy your relationship with yourself
and then anybody else who comes in they
enter into a party you already started
yeah yeah and then the relationship with
your kids the relationship with your
spouse the relationship with your
friends taking time to enjoy the
relationships because there is no fruit
nature teaches us that there is no fruit
without relationships you cannot be
fruitful by yourself in business in home
not in life in church I don't care what
it is you are no more than the
relationships you surround yourself with
and make sure that those are good ones
well number nine just start how many
people did you have in your first
congregation at seven
I started I mean having a congregation
today over 30,000 over 30,000 that
didn't just happen overnight no it
didn't happen overnight and everyone in
the book I talk about the pressures in
the stress and I founded the church
she's not like a board hired me and I
came in I work a job I'm not a hired gun
that means I did the paintin and the
cleaning and the rent negotiating and
hiring the staff as we finally got staff
I went through all of that process from
the ground up and not only that what a
lot of people know me as a preacher but
they don't know my entertainment company
is older than the Potter's House and I
started that company with a little bit
of money started touring around the
country doing plays and entertainment
things like that stumbled into an
opportunity to do a movie stumbled into
an opportunity to enter into a contract
with Sony Pictures who is my partner in
producing movies that have grossed over
500 million dollars at the box office
what I'm saying is it doesn't matter
where you start it matters where you
finish and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is pull
out the weeds I had a friend of mine who
did a film when I first gave my film and
I did my first movie a woman our Allison
and we did it out here we did it in 400
screams and it did pretty good I mean we
met the budget paid the bills now and
about it a few hamburgers and that was
it and and he did his film and it blew
up and it went crazy and every time
somebody said something about how good
it was I felt funny I did I felt funny I
feel funny and I was Travis funny was
the word funny I felt it was funny to me
because I had never felt the feeling
before I just wasn't happy
I wasn't happy and I was ashamed that I
wasn't happy and I called myself on the
carpet and say what is this and and I
had to look myself I said you jealous
and I have never Tamil always been
jealous about anybody or anything in my
life
I was jealous and I thought I don't want
that in my heart I don't want that in my
heart so what I did every day like that
I sold tickets for it
I put on events for it I got behind it
and pushed it and - and all wild they
thought I was pushing his movie what I
was doing was pushing jealousy out of my
heart I don't want that admit I don't
want that in me and that that's what I
mean about an idea against an idea you
have to fight an ideology with a better
idea the better idea was to help him and
when I started helping him it
immediately left me when you see
something growing up in you and we all
are human it will happen and you see it
and you don't want it you don't want it
in you do the opposite do the absolute
opposite do the thing that is most
unlikely for you to do and when you do
that that idea will come down out of
your head and it never came back again
and I was so happy and I was so proud of
myself because though he didn't know
that I felt that way jealousy in slaves
of the its landlord and so what happens
I end up incarcerated everybody else is
having a good time and I'm sitting in
Tibet you know I'm saying and then guess
what then God started blessed mind you
you can't curse the light in your
neighbor's window and expect the light
in your house to still burn you just
can't do it and what I am saying Maria
is that we all have the propensity to be
evil to be jealous to be angry to be
deceitful so let's not act like there
are good people and bad people they're
just people
when you see those weeds growing in your
garden you got to pull them up and the
best way to pull them up is by using the
opposite of the idea that you don't want
to be a tenant in your heart
now I've got a special bonus clip from
TD jakes on how to be ready for success
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your business
or your life and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what weeds do you need to pull out
number two
what does work-life balance look like
for you and number three what
relationship will you make count this
week
you have to know something about things
that you haven't received yet you've got
to start reading things you've never
read before going to places who've never
gone before so that when God opens the
door you're not trying to get ready to
overtake
oh one one sings one song
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want some business advice from TD
jakes check out the video we did on his
new books or the link is right there
next to me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
soar when I sat down to write it was
written solely and exclusively to people
who had inspirations